[Musique]
je voudrais te proposer un travail un
braquage assez unique parce qu'on ne va
pas s'en prendre à leur argent
notre cible c'est quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous
[Musique]
ce masque est finalement devenu un
symbole et nous nous sommes la
résistance
et nous tous on nous appelle les robins
des bois
on sera ce qui serait injuste
[Musique]
on peut partir en couille en un millième
de seconde
l'état nous a déclaré la guerre
et nous n'allons pas nous cacher
nous allons nous battre en
alerte pour tout le monde
il n'y a pas de grandes batailles sans
grand adversaire
[Musique]
surtout berne
vous ne pouvez pas sortir envie de la
banque d'espagne
c'est impossible
mais je vais tous vous tirez pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]